métro ouvrira un nouveau centre de
distribution à terrebonne ce nouveau
centre automatisé de plus de 600 mille
pieds carrés permettra l'épicier de
regrouper les centres existants de
montréal-nord et de pointe aux trembles
métro est le plus important employeur du
secteur privé au québec depuis son achat
du groupe jean coutu avec nous éric
laflèche président de métro bonsoir
monsieur la flèche bon sens suffit
qu'est ce que ça va vous permettre vous
apportez que la création de la
construction de ce nouveau centre
automatisé
mais cet investissement majeur qu'on
annonce si au québec aujourd'hui pour la
construction d'un nouveau centre
automatisé
on a eu beaucoup de croissance au cours
des dernières années et nos
installations actuelles ont des enjeux
des espaces et d'efficacité autant dans
la viande et les produits surgelés que
dans les produits des fruits de la mer
alors on a analysé toutes nos options on
l'a choisi de relocaliser dans un
nouveau centre à la fine pointe
technologique yvette à terrebonne
c'est un investissement majeur 420
millions pour celui là le nouveau semble
600 mille pieds et aussi pour grandir
notre centre de fruits et légumes à
laval qui était construit seulement en
2013 mais là la croissance des volumes
de fruits et légumes est telle qu'on a
besoin d'espacé 10 ionel alors on va en
profiter pour faire cet investissement
là aussi ces deux investissements au
cours des quatre prochaines années qui
vont nous permettre de continuer à
croire et de continuer à bien servir nos
magasins et nos consommateurs et que
vous allez financer comment à même nos
liquidités et nos ressources financières
on a un bilan solide chez métro et les
liquidités que l'entreprise génère nous
permet de faire ces investissements dans
nos infrastructures ce sont donc des
investissements en automatisation en
robotisation en amélioration de
l'efficacité est ce que ça veut dire
moins d'employés
toutes choses étant égales willy réu
licenciement parce que la mode la
robotisation veut dire moins d'employés
mais il va y avoir plus de volume dans
notre sens de distribution à terrebonne
qui en a aujourd'hui dans nation de
montréal-nord et on va on va avoir de la
croissance et on va rapatrier du volume
qui est fait en ce moment par des tiers
distributeurs ou même par nos
fournisseurs envers nos magasins parce
qu'on n'a pas la capacité alors
l'augmentation du volume dans le nouveau
centre de faire en sorte qu'il n'y aura
pas de mises à pied on aura besoin de
tout tous les toutes les personnes qui
travaillent dans nos centres
actuellement donc les heureux
normes en rien à un autre point très
localisé à terrebonne
oui y'a pas de coupures d'emplois à
terme alors ils vont des périodes de
transition
mais à la fin de la journée on va voir à
peu près le même nombre d'employés qu'on
a aujourd'hui dans cet environnement
moderne êtes à combien d'employés en ce
moment dans tout métro parce qu'elle
métro a acheté le groupe jean coutu ça
vous donne un total de combien
d'employés au métro et ses 90 mille
emplois directs et indirects
alors chez métro c'est environ une
cinquantaine de milles d'emplois ouais
et nous magasins affiliés les
pharmaciens franchisés jean coutu et
brunet ont leur part faisant primer tout
ça c'est environ 90 milles personnes qui
travaillent dans le réseau m comment se
passe vous allez dire en distribution au
regard de distribution ces
investissements là et environ 1300
personnes au québec qui sont en
instruction dans nos entrepôts les
entrepôts qui sont concernés ici on
parle d'environ 450 emplois alors
comment se passe l'intégration de jean
coutu que vous avez achetés en 2010
deviez wauquiez des synergies à l'époque
c'est à dire qu'il fallait trouver
l'efficacité réduire de 75 millions si
je me trompe pas est ce que s'y attend
pas encore on a dit qu'on n'atteindrait
le 75 millions après trois ans alors on
approche le deuxième anniversaire et
même après 1 1 on atteint 65 millions
des 75 millions de synergies prévues sur
cet excellent on est sur notre plan mais
on a dit que ça prendrait trois ans
parce que le solde des synergies va
provenir de la combinaison des de la
distribution pharmaceutique alors on ne
sent de distribution pharmacie mcmann
qui est à montréal il le sang de jean
coutu qui est à varennes
notre plan c'est à terme de combiner les
deux cheikhs jean coutu à varennes pour
inciter encore fait il ya une convention
collective qui est en négociations avec
les employés de gens au dessus on a bon
espoir qu'on va s'entendre et qu'on va
avoir une entente à long terme et on va
pouvoir passer à la phase 2 pour
compléter notre intégration de la
distribution formation c'est ce divo
pharmacies jean coutu et brunet
surpassent les attentes selon les
derniers résultats financiers
c'est fermé ses pharmacies l'a atteinte
des objectifs au delà des attentes au
niveau des ventes au détail commerciale
et de prescription nos performances sont
satisfaisants dont les très satisfait
des résultats
nos pharmacies les synergies ça ne se
passe pas ce niveau la selle se passe au
niveau de la chaîne d'approvisionnement
la distribution et de l'administration
très bien c'est ça et dans les ventes
chez métro des résultats moins bons pour
démontrer mais on a eu des bons
résultats au dernier trimestre un
calendrier un peu un peu en bas des
attentes parce qu'on a un effet de
calendrier un peu spécial chez métro
notre premier trimestre à une fin de
trimestre qui varient par rapport à noël
à chacun dise oui c'est l'excusé les
vraies raisons
c'est la vraie raison c'est le réseau
lundi au marché ce qui va falloir
attendre le deuxième trimestre pour voir
le premier et le deuxième trimestre
semble qu est ce que ça donne on a dit
que nous nous étions entêtés bon premier
trimestre et notre deuxième trimestre
déclaré au mois d'avril on a confiance
que ce qu'on a dit qu'en communiste en
combinant les deux trimestres comment
vont des résultats satisfaisants cela
dit le monde de l'épicerie et du
commerce de détail en général mais
l'épicerie c'est une bataille sans merci
entre soubise entre l'aube là entre vous
vous devez chercher de l'efficacité
parce que les marges sont extrêmement
faibles nous en a mis deux concurrents
il y en a plein d'autres lieu des géants
américains que ce soit ou marcos cook de
dos des surfaces et magasins dollars des
pharmacies tout le monde vend de
l'alimentation alors c'est un marché
hyper concurrentiel il faut exécuter il
faut avoir des bonnes stratégies de mise
en marché
je me trouve je pense qu'on a une très
bonne équipe de bonnes manières des
bonnes parts de marché surtout au québec
puis on s'en tire bien notre jeu
votre entreprise compte maintenant aussi
des caisses libre service dans plus de
100 magasins et vous prévoyez d'oubli ce
nombre en 2020 est-ce que ce déploiement
est une réponse à la rareté de
main-d'oeuvre aussi ces deux choses
c'est pour refaire un meilleur service à
la clientèle plus de rapidité les gens
sont pressés on est des commerces de
proximité surtout alors les gens
n'aiment pas attendre aux caisses on
essaie de minimiser soit toujours avec
des caisses
allez hors service le temps d'attenté
boudeuse beaucoup réduit ça fait ça fait
ça fait plaisir beaucoup de clients
c'est populaire on en installe de plus
en plus elles sont utilisées en plus ça
nous permet de sauver des heures dont
des plus productifs dans nos magasins
puis ça répond à un problème de pénurie
de main-d'oeuvre aussi alors c'est
comment bien monsieur la flèche merci
beaucoup merci moi qui vous remercie au
plaisir